okay why don't we go ahead and get
started want to welcome everyone to our
weekly conference so we have a nice
robust turnout today I don't doubt any
reason why it's because we're going to
hear two presentations from students in
the program who these two groups are two
of the final or finalists at the a mia
meeting in a couple weeks in the student
design challenge and so it's certainly
as a source of great pride for the
faculty in the program that the students
have been successful in doing this and
of course i'm sure it's a great pride
for for them as well so as always we are
streaming this presentation I just
tweeted out the length and as always if
people want to ask a question they just
ask it with the hashtag demise comp and
someone probably in this case me will be
monitoring Twitter during this talk so
why don't we just go ahead and get
started our first group presenting
consists of Michelle rye bar Nelson
Sanchez Pinto Kate volt Alice Jean Ren
and deb Woodcock I assume that Nelson
and Kate's are probably listening and
I'm certain that Kate
she'll let me know and then we'll hear
second from Ben courtier and Jason Lee
another nice aspect of this is that well
actually both of the projects have
somewhat of a clinical orientation one's
a little more BCB ish anyway so I think
it's gene that's going to start and the
title of their presentation is learning
from the data exploring a hepatocellular
carcinoma registry using visual
analytics to improve multidisciplinary
clinical decision-making
so welcome everybody my name is Jean
Brennen I'm excited to be here to
present to you our team project titled
learning from the data exploring a
hepatocellular carcinoma registry using
visual analytics to improve clinical
decision-making so our project started
with a case a use case study with dr.
Scott nodular team their team is part of
the epithelial carcinoma treating
patients in a multidisciplinary system
and so after meeting with dr. Scott nah
glaring and getting his ideas about the
needs that his team needs to have a
multi-disciplinary tool to capture the
critical data during their tumor board
conferences allowed us to come up with
the our student challenge which is to be
able to analyze the national national
hepatocellular carcinoma registry and to
be able to access that data in a very
useful way and quick way that's
applicable to the treatment process
so current the current situation is that
data tends to look be located regionally
and not shared amongst the different
healthcare systems and the guideline for
hepatocellular carcinoma is not
necessarily the most effective even
those a guideline that can be used and
and the treatment of hepatocellular
carcinoma is arreted directly and so we
wanted to be able to capture the process
and the data in a meaningful way and so
we did in addition to scott nog leurs
multidisciplinary file format data tool
our tool will work alongside of that
tool pulling relevant data from the
national registry and using data
analytics and visualization to find
meaning meaning in this uh data so we we
did field interviews with the clinicians
and we also attended board meetings see
the actual case scenarios of when
they're in their tumor board meetings
what's going on and where where are the
data in the inefficiencies and so a lot
of times during the tumor board meetings
there's a lot of domain expertise such
as oncology radiology surgery pathology
and they all have their domain expertise
and they're giving their best advice on
treating the patient but the data is not
being captured and so hence the problem
with not being able to aggregate data
for clinical decision making
and so this diagram here is symbolic of
on the on the right side is a lot of big
data on the other side on the left side
is more or less a simpler form of the
data analytics but how can we combine
the two into a meaningful way and
applicable way to treat patient care and
so the diagram below is John's the
famous Jon Snow cholera outbreak and he
actually mapped the location of cholera
and then found that cholera was from a
certain well and so so the idea is that
we can combine both the clinical data as
well as the big data from hepatocellular
carcinoma registry and make it
meaningful for the clinicians the
scientists the people trying to find use
of this data and Michelle will give you
guys a demo okay so problem that we were
encountering when we started doing field
interviews with clinicians is when we
asked them what they needed and what
they wanted for the data visualizations
they had a very difficult time sort of
putting that into words or even
envisioning what was possible and you
know what I keep falling back on is that
famous Steve Jobs quote was that a lot
of times people have a really hard time
knowing what they want until you show it
to them so this is sort of the idea that
we that sort of spurred what we came up
with so we decided that instead of
trying us trying to create
visualizations for the clinicians and
just giving them to them that really
this is a much bigger process and what
we really need is community involvement
in a platform that supports that type of
community development so we really need
clinicians on the one hand data
visualization experts and fermentations
on the other hand to be able to come
together in a commune
beware they're often not located in the
same place and both are busy and don't
have a lot of time so the idea we came
up with was this website which will
serve as a repository for the
visualizations that are developed but
also help support these visualizations
before they're developed so this is a
place where place will work I guess it's
not ok ok there we go so this is the
website and the idea is that we will
collect these visualizations so that
people can browse them get ideas for new
visualizations and when they have a
clinical question they can post it to a
discussion forum the visualization
experts can start responding and they
can start discussing ideas brainstorm
and brain starting with other clinicians
and then coming up with a mock-up once
you have a mock-up then it can be posted
here and it will contain all sorts of
information about the visualization not
just the visualization itself so it's
the status you know where is in the
process who's created it with the
purpose is any publications and
evaluations have been done with it but
also it now provides the place where you
can directly comment on it and not just
in the forums so just giving an example
of an initial visualization that we came
up with what in discussions with the gym
Awards team here at ohsu was that they
really wanted to be able to see a
visualization where they could sort of
define a patient cohort by
characteristics of the patients so these
are represented by the filters up here
and then be able to look at a certain
number of treatments and figure out at
this point which treatment you know is
best for this patient so we can look
here we can see what our baseline is
what our cohort how many you know sort
of match this and then we can branch off
into for the first treatment
different options and we can see each of
these cohorts how big they are you know
sort of what their 12 months survival is
quality of life that kind of thing
they're different lab results are
scoring and then because treatment is
iterative we can continue this process
and sort of see what happens when you
start you know doing these successive
treatments and seeing what happens to
the cohorts so this was sort of this is
one example visualization another one is
looking at labs over time so this is
also an interactive visualization and
the nice thing about having these
visualizations on a website and having
them be live even though they at this
point our only based on sample data is
that you know clinicians can actually
play with them so they can you know play
with the graph they can look at a
particular lab value look at the range
that they want to sort of see how that
changes over time you can see that this
is a bunch of lab values over time and
they can rearrange them if they want to
see you know I want to see what happens
to inr over six months for this type of
patient cohort that kind of thing and
being able to interactively test it
allows the clinicians then to get better
feedback here and develop it and let it
become something that is actually useful
I don't know why I can't present anymore
okay
well I hope this doesn't happen at a mia
and he went ahead to make suggestions
and not yeah
do you know I cantaloupe yeah okay
thanks that's a helpful trip to now
that's it well can I try you're
projecting it now full screen
okay great thank you then also data
visualization experts if they come here
and they start engaging the clinicians
or have some ideas for visualizations
they can download their own their own
data as well so the idea is that this
website will support user centered
design in a way that allows the
developers to have access to you busy
users in an asynchronous way but an easy
way as well so the idea the clinician
has a clinical question posts it to the
website there's some discussion there's
some visualization development and this
is iterative and eventually once the
visualization becomes mature enough then
it will be tested in a real situation
with real clinicians and real data and
once this is evaluated will be included
in the MDB d tool that's being developed
and can be used actually in conference
for making clinical decisions at that
point though we don't want to just stop
there we want to make sure that we're
evaluating everything that we're doing
and we're documenting it so we want to
make sure that we can evaluate the
effect of the visualization on the
clinical decision making so there are
tools out there that measure the level
of how well clinical decisions are made
in groups and so that can be we can use
that tool before and after the
visualization using the visualization to
see if it improves decision making and
also we can do evaluation later of a
patient outcomes based you know after
using these visualization and then we
can induce a door closes the loop back
to the clinical question to see if we've
actually made improvement so the
potential impact of this is that you
know unlocking this national data that
hasn't been available before can really
help enhance HCC treatment being able to
see sort of different patterns that
different organizations or institutions
use across the country allows you know
people to see a much broader view of how
patients do they really can't do
prospective studies on a lot of these
treatment sequences like if you do this
treatment followed by that
by that treatment and so being able to
have this sort of data and looking back
at it retrospectively can help make
better decisions for the future and this
idea of creating visualizations that are
custom designed for the clinicians
themselves so they have input in how
they're created is something that they
is very useful to them and also this
concept there's nothing about it that
says that it has to be focused only on
HTC it could be extended to other
cancers and diseases certainly you know
they could be included in the website
you know sort of start looking at the
visualizations that are being done
seeing if they apply to different
diseases or you know creating other
similar websites that are focused on a
particular disease so as of now six
users have evaluated it and the response
has been overwhelmingly positive they
really like the clinical engagement in
the development of the visualizations
and they stress that any feedback in
this whole process is iterative
development has to be very fascinating
because clinicians are very busy and
don't have a lot of time but they were
very excited about this idea of sort of
making visualizations that they want for
the data that they have and the clinical
decisions that they need to be making so
a roadmap looking forward is you know
right now we really need to start
actually building the website you know
developing it from its prototype and one
of the focuses of that will be creating
a pilot visualization for the MDB d tool
which so do beat it should be deployed
the beginning of next year and the next
year or beginning end of the share
beginning of next year and it's sort of
one of the ideas for this is that you
know if we start getting a visualization
in there sort of at the beginning it can
also be help entice that the adoption
and you know sort of the you know for
its enticement for people to adopt the
tool to use it so and then of course
we'll need to make sure that we're
recruiting members for the community
both clinicians and data visualization
experts who can contribute and create
more visualizations and possibly
include other cancers and diseases as
well so giving clinicians access to hcc
registry data about patients that hasn't
been accessible before is really in an
exciting things for these clinicians and
they think will really help improve
clinical decision making data
visualizations will have a tremendous a
potential for impacting this process and
the hope is it will create a very rapid
learning environment for this type of
treatment and it's something that
requires community participation effort
to succeed but we think that it's
something that people will be pretty
excited and motivated to participate in
so just to acknowledge dr. Scott nodular
is the mastermind behind md BD to land
this person who really helped guide our
development of this and ideas of how
visualizations can be used for this data
and how we actually create visualization
the ohsu hcc tumor board who let us sit
in and and the development team and then
all the different clinicians that we
talked to here at OU h issue and of
course I'm do mice for the support any
questions xai don't I don't have a
question but well it's a sort of process
question I actually realized as you were
talking I didn't ask you about the time
how long are you given to present is it
like 15 minutes yeah okay so you were
timing it okay great yeah and and also
one of your co-presenters tweeted in
looks great so far and then a second
computer stalling good for practice
visuals make you stop and think how the
information looks and can help you make
decisions so hopefully that won't happen
in San Francisco
oh this is dr. Scott knock larvae um so
yeah 2 comments um one is it if this is
I'm not sure exactly what the audience
is I'm sure it's not people like me but
kind of more bioinformatics but it might
be helpful if you even do just a little
run-through of one patient okay um when
you're doing that kind of thing is I
think it it it might make more sense
that way or just be more intuitive that
mean what kind segments just a comment
um we're developing the tool um just two
weeks ago I talked to a team from GE the
big GE they make many many things a huge
company amongst them our scanners like
MRIs and cat-scans and they are trying
to develop a tool and I just say this is
this is very very cutting edge and
people are nipping at your and our heels
and they they have things we don't have
like tons of resources but they don't
have things that we do have like you
know all of availability of clinicians
and kind of the academic environments I
just want to encourage you to keep going
you just say this is it's it's whether
this seems like it's great idea or not
other people have had it it is a great
idea and it's certainly going to be
expanding nationwide great thank you
just to reiterate some of that so I'm
Jim Morrison interventional radiologist
and we deal with these thatís other
carcinoma patients all the time and I
kid you not in the last month I've had
discussions in addition to the GE people
about doing exactly that tool so I'm
jealous because you beat me to the punch
it's this is a tremendous project and
yeah I'd be happy to help out I know you
said in the future you're going to be
looking for clinicians to be involved so
because this is really cool great yeah
we really want involvement from anyone
who's interested from the clinician side
in fermentation side data data
visualization side yeah that's a good
question one of the in Scott since you
see Eric's probably answer this a little
bit better than I can but one of the
things that is important with the data
collection is that it's done in a very
structured way because the data that we
have now on the HR is not and so it's
very difficult to analyze or do anything
with so that's part of this M dbg tool
is creating data inputs facilities that
make it so that it's very structured
very regular and that the data hopefully
will be gathered well that doesn't mean
of course that someone can't make a
mistake and choose the wrong option but
the the workflow will be that the nurse
would be in charge of getting the data
collected about the patients before the
tumor board and initially that means the
nurse is actually going to be entering
it herself eventually there's probably
going to be facilities for grabbing it
from the EHR but even if that were the
case the nurse would be reviewing all
the cases before the tumor board and
then the tools used in the tumor board
meeting to present the patient so that's
another opportunity to see the data and
hopefully you know catch any errors
record any treatment decisions any
outcomes from discussions and then that
data gets stored locally and then
eventually do you identified instance
back to the national registry so we're
hoping that there's opportunities to
catch any errors as they the processes
that goes on
there's actually a question from the
twittersphere how much do you think the
visual a visualization process will cost
in the long run wow I what do you think
Deb you're on the business management
side you know part of this goal and you
know from my perspective is it would be
nice to you know have this be sort of
you know community involvement have it
be open source have the visualizations
developed and be available obviously
they're being created to be included in
this tool and so you you know if you're
using if you're trying to do it for hcc
you would need the tool to eventually
use the visualization in real time but
that doesn't mean that we couldn't have
open source versions of the
visualizations that would be available
to adapt to other diseases and for
anyone else's data that that they have
so you know the hope is you know if we
can create sort of an open source
environment where people are willing to
contribute but obviously that still is
some sort of involved some sort of money
and support yeah I mean it and it's
conceivable you'd have to do things like
clinical trials but if they actually
would lead to more cost-effective care
than you know it could exit paper itself
right right um Nathan I think this film
I guess along those lines I guess is a
comment would it make sense to set up
some kind of a bounty system or
community funding system so that you
know if someone really wants a
visualization they can all pitch in
some money for the developing time
that's yeah yeah sort of we I thought of
the idea of crowdsourcing the ideas but
crowdsourcing the funding is certainly a
good one as well um the clinical data
that you get that your that your
clinical expert enters I wasn't quite
clear in the format of it but are you
using any tools like the disease
ontology to make sure that the day that
you enter isn't just in your HCC silo
but can be used in other forms of the
patient's treatment and you know you can
use the the power of semantic
semantically enable tools to make your
data more useful and that's a really
good question um jun Scott do you know
if that's part of the development well
okay so I dressed two kinds of things
first thing is the fidelity great
question and um I've been you know
pitching this idea or similar for at
least six years and all computer people
the first thing they say is ability data
and and most people would like to
connect these tools with electronic
medical record okay and I have been
extremely
not because it isn't a great idea which
is it just takes a lot of resources and
the power of this kind of tool is that
it's done at many centers nationally all
of which may have different medical
records and this this creates difficulty
so I think ultimately connect me into
the medical record is a great idea but
initially it's it's very difficult and
that's the same kind of answer to your
question I mean there's going to be all
this captured data which is going to be
very robust for this condition and could
you integrate it with other you know
healthcare stuff and I I would love that
I would love it if we could integrate
with kind of our other medical records
but I just for me because I not GE with
unlimited resources we just got to start
somewhere and so we're just starting on
that and that no one's at 11 anything so
this is this is like specific for this
liver cancer thing and it's very good
this need is across many diseases
especially cancers and there's super
opportunities um because um all the
cancers have these kind of boards but
they have different specific data needs
and for example we are not dependent on
genetic data and if this liver cancer
has really not evolved to the point
where genetic it is use bold all the
time but if you go to other cancers like
leukemia there isn't genetic data every
single day it's very complicated and it
needs to be incorporated into exactly
this same exact kind of thing with just
little tweaks but the overall idea is
the same you know but anyways my point
is that the genetic it just has to be in
there for clinical use I was just going
to add if you're going to employ a human
to add terms or input data you might as
well use you know structured structured
terms so that your information we can be
connected to other forms of data it
doesn't require any more resources right
right yeah that's a good question yeah
sure we can go on the team will stick
around so we can have the the next team
come up actually I would I would answer
the the last question is is that all of
the brilliant students in this room will
create the future interoperable data and
EHR systems that will allow us to easily
push the data in but we're not quite
there yet we still need for Meaningful
Use to figure the rest of that out okay
so while these folks are slowly getting
set up here I guess I can introduce
their title so I've already introduced
oxa I I guess it's been in jacent
presenting it's a larger team here
Ashley Choi been courtier bernardus and
Jason Lee and they're the second of the
two teams that are among the final four
at the a mia meeting and the title of
their talk is their presentations take a
breather empowering adherence and
patient-centered research through
interactive data visualization social
engagement in gamification in patients
with sleep apnea
alright thank you for that introduction
I'm Jason Lee and this is Ben Corriere
and where we started no commercial
interests or financial conflicts of
interest sleep apnea is a disease that
affects 25 million Americans and eighty
percent can go undiagnosed and it's
characterized by frequent cessations of
breathing at night so people often wake
up up to hundreds of times a night
gasping for breath or choking and they
also because they're waking up there
sleepy during the day which leads to
decreased cognitive function memory loss
attention deficit and depression and
they have also increased risk for
hypertension and heart attack and
obesity and diabetes so the gold
standard treatment for sleep apnea is a
CPAP or continuous positive airway
pressure and it's basically the patient
wears a mask when he or she goes to
sleep and it's connected by a hose to
this small machine that blows air into
their airway to keep it open also since
it's comorbid with obesity weight loss
is a very effective treatment and so
these changes are basically very simple
behavior modifications
but we have found that a patient
compliance is surprisingly low we found
that about forty six percent of patients
comply with their CPAP adherence a CPAP
treatment regularly
so the Chalin the student design
challenge was meant for to engage people
with their data and we sought to focus
on the challenge of patient engagement
with their data so with long-term
therapy like cancer treatment or sleep
apnea treatment patients often have
inconsistent health improvement or it's
unnoticeable they don't see the
long-term trend and so they get
discouraged and they may stop their
treatment or not adhere to their
doctor's orders also patients may feel
all alone in their treatment even if
they have a strong family support system
they're the only ones who are actually
going through the disease and this leads
to feelings of isolation and so poor
adherence leads to negative health
outcomes this project was a
collaboration between us and my apnea
org and we were connected through an 0 h
su taxi dr. Boudreau who had worked with
them at Harvard and this group is funded
by Corey the patient-centered outcomes
Research Institute which seeks to make
patients more informed so they make
informed decisions about their health
care and the my apnea mission my apnea
is a resource for learning about sleep
apnea
um they have placed a forum where
patients can suggest their research
direction for sleep apnea and connect
with each other and they're trying to
expand their website and it's constantly
growing and evolving and also sleep
apnea is a natural case for a use case
for what we're trying to do because it's
a chronic disease and they're collecting
all this data from their CPAP machine
and modern sleep and they're they're not
engaging with it so we wanted to find a
way to make this data more engageable so
our desired solution was to make an app
that allowed patients to increase their
understanding of their own health
through interactive data visualization
so the patient can set their own
personal health goals such as a target
weight and they'll earn achievements
like in a game for reaching these
targets also there could be a social
social module where the patient can
connect with others through social media
and ideally the data collection for this
app would be continuous and automated
and we wanted to make this modular so
that we could
tuning Li add new features and so the
concept the concept we came up with was
a modular dashboard web app for personal
health and treatment tracking that would
increase these the patient understanding
and we started off with three modules
data collection interactive data
visualization and gamification and we
came up with a working prototype that
been here will explain to you so the
first module I want to share with you
guys is the data collection module and
this is pretty standard web form and
what this would do would it would
collect weight data blood pressure heart
rate and other sleep quality measures
such as how long a patient use their
CPAP for the night before their daytime
sleepiness the next day and the
perceived sleep quality so this is all
fairly standard data that is often used
in a treatment of sleep apnea once this
data is in the system it would be used
to power a gamification module and the
gamification module would first have
standard goals that would drive the
patients towards achieving certain
health outcomes some of these metals
they could get would be a data dignitary
for consistent data entry for a survey
samurai metal for filling out surveys on
my apnea they have a number of long-term
engagement surveys that they have been
using for some while form friend for
responding to user posts on forms and
then also a thought leader metal that
would
allow them to essentially gain clout
through posting research crest questions
in a rank of research tool posted on my
apnea the more upvotes they receive the
more clout they get until they start
achieving metals of the satyrs and the
levels are broken up into gold silver
and bronze in addition to these standard
metals a more robust version of this
module would also include the ability to
set your own goals and that way you
could really personalize this module and
allow patients to really set their own
health goals and better their own health
and all this in addition to the
gamification module this would all be
used to power a data visualization
module and this data visualization
module would allow you to filter through
the data collected and pan and zoom and
engage with finer time points and as you
mouse over these data points you would
get a tooltip that gives you a more
granular explanation of the data for a
specific day and I actually have a live
version right here that I can share and
it looks like minimize this a bit but as
you can see you can add in different
filters that's blood pressure and weight
right here and then you can mouse over
and you can zoom in to it seems to be
wanting to scroll you can also pan and
then this is the very standard input
module and then the gamification module
which doesn't seem to like the current
dimensions of the screen
so all this would be in a modular
software design that would allow for the
dashboard to be extended to the future
this would allow for the integration of
mobile and wearable technologies as they
are used more by the general population
and members of the community and it
would also allow for the integration of
medical devices as their data streams
become available to currently this is a
front end prototype but when it does
become integrated it would be integrated
on the my ántonia web server and this
integration would actually it would be
using the same REST API and database as
a the apple health kit app that is
currently undeveloped under development
by mi apnea in addition to any other
wearable apps that they would develop in
the future by integrating all this we
would then have mobile and wearable data
streams made available to the dashboard
and we could build out future modules
that allow users to explore their mobile
health data through the web application
so once we came up with this concept and
built the prototype we shared it with
the team at my apnea specifically the
leader of the patient engagement panel
to members of the steering committee and
we were iterating with one of the
developers and from this sharing and
collaboration we found recommendations
for additional modules and also
discussed further integrating the
healthcare app and wearables we also got
some really valuable feedback from a
sleep physician who encouraged the use
of more metrics to contextualize the
ones we were currently gathering and to
also use more validated metrics such as
the Stanford sleepiness scale and so
these would be things to extend this
dashboard prototype to in the future so
future directions would include the
integration with the Miami a server and
make use making use of their wet REST
API the integration and from this
integration really tapping into those
wearable sensors and data feeds and also
the developers at Miami are currently
using a software or exploring the use of
a software called sleepy head which
normalizes cpap data between
manufacturers and brands and there are
different devices and from this
normalization sleepyhead allows for data
visualizations so using that technology
it would be great to be able to
visualize CPAP data directly from one of
these modules in addition a refinement
of the metrics and the inclusion of more
objective validated data would really
take this to the next level so also like
to give many thanks to the team members
the people at my apnea our advisors I
Boudreau and Shannon mcweeny and
additional thank yous to ohsu demise a
mia and of course deb who provided us
some great feedback and information on
the Meo design challenge well thank you
any questions I actually have one from
the Twitterverse what if patients don't
like games um that's entirely possible I
think that you know we're not really
tapping into games as much as this
gamification psychological research
which shows that if you put a progress
bar somewhere people are really likely
to do those achieve the milestones that
they need to to fill that progress bar
if you have a LinkedIn you may see that
they put how far you can go to improve
your profile are you an expert yet and
so that sort of psychology is really
what we're trying to tap into to
encourage people to adhere to their
treatments and to really engage with my
apnea door
yes
yeah so I think when it comes to the
data collection our current input module
was really something made for the
prototype I think ideally an input
module would be the fall back we would
ideally like to be getting data streams
directly from mobile devices that said
there is still valuable information you
can get from input modules and the data
we were collecting was blood pressure
heart rate and BMI which can actually
inform a lot of the risk factors for my
apnea or sorry sleep apnea and also like
a lot of the data was actually survey
data like like how how sleepy do you
feel it's believe so so you could assess
that with the Stanford sleepiness scale
so it's it's subjective but quantified
and something I also actually didn't
point out is that the state of
visualization its current iteration it's
really on it's on it's a user's view of
their data but the ideal implementation
would actually make heavy use of social
integration so allowing a user to
compare their data and averages by
site-wide averages and then also being
able to share the badges they achieve in
the gamification module across social
media such as Twitter and Facebook
things like that yes
our hope is that essentially the these
patients are often on treatment plans
that encourage the reduction of weight
and exercising because these are known
to alleviate a lot of the symptoms of
sleep apnea now assuming they are
following these treatment plans the hope
is that they would be able to see the
benefits through these visualizations by
having an improved heart rate lower
blood pressure and decreasing BMI over
time so it's really their their
continuous inputting of the data in
engagement with this dashboard would
allow them to gain some of that insight
into their own health and really see
where they've come from and where
they're heading
um yeah that's that's not something
we've explored yet and we've been
focused on this leave at me a use case
but i think this given that there
probably is a pack or ii diabetes
website i'm actually not sure but
there's quite a few of them out there
right now this is something that could
definitely extend it across patient
sites and with
right so my question is there are some
other apps out there that give some kind
of feedback about sleep so that i know
some of them are on the iphone does this
would this tool potentially pick up
information about that visualize those
data too so it certainly could that's
part of the modularity of the design our
hope is that if someone essentially
requests that we allow them to integrate
a certain app that we could build out of
module to do that if it doesn't already
exist my understanding is that the
health kit app will also have similar
features so it's possible that we could
encourage users to migrate over to that
to get more into involved with my apnea
community but stuffing something to
explore other questions
thank you
hello
really
you